[Music]
in the summer of 1884 for English
sailors were stranded at sea in a
lifeboat in the South Atlantic
over a thousand miles from land Dudley
was the captain Stevens the first mate
and Brooks a sailor the fourth member of
the crew was the cabin boy Richard
Parker age 17 the crew had few
provisions for the first three days they
ate a can of turnips on the fourth day
they caught a turtle which sustained
them for a time but soon they had no
food and for eight days they ate nothing
by now Parker the cabin boy
was lying in the corner of the boat he
had drunk seawater and become ill and
the 19th day Dudley the captain
suggested drawing lots to determine who
would die so that the others might live
but Brooks refused and no lots were
drawn the next day
Dudley decided that Parker had to be
killed
he offered a prayer told the boy his
time had come and killed him with a pen
knife stabbing him in the jugular vein
for four days the three remaining crew
members fed on the body and the blood of
the Kevin boy then help came on the 24th
day a ship rescued the three survivors
upon their return to England they were
arrested and put on trial for murder
Dudley and Stephens confessed that they
had killed an Eton Parker but they
claimed they had done so out of
necessity putting aside the question of
law how do you judge the morality of
what they did would you say they acted
immorally
in killing and eating the cabin boy or
would you say that all things considered
they did the right thing
sacrificing one life in order to save
three
you
[Music]